yes Salaam to this brother he wants to
give her out yeah here again yes mr.
Amin recorded movies are like much Anna
how are you brother - he's indeed Moody
[Music]
Malik emotional Salah you forgot you
brothers and sisters in Islam inshallah
all of you are in the best of health any
man and you're doing fine
you guys are tuning in to another
episode of Oscar share we have our
beloved Church intimacies are with us
today once again and what we're going to
be discussing today in sha Allah is [ __ ]
let's get straight into it a lot of
youngsters nowadays of course they want
to get married you know we were all at
that stage one at one point and a lot of
sisters specifically they want to get
married we find the brother they like
each other they want to take it the
halal route the sister she takes it to
appearance and her parents say no but
for know Islamic reason so they say no
maybe because of the brothers race or
maybe because of something very petty
because they don't want her to marry for
example a brother from a different race
you know so what is the ruling and was
there like advice in regards to this
yeah developer salam ala rasoolillah
well to be honest to you this is a big
and huge and there are a number of
angles that need to be tackled in order
to understand the full picture it's not
as simple as as it is now okay
first of all let us start all the way
from the beginning and now this sister
how did she find that rhythm this is the
first question yes we're gay lose in
terms of their relationship when they
were studying at this college or
university or maybe at work or some even
Islamic Islamic Dawa activity here yes
they were loose with each of them and
they become attached to each other and
they want to get married to each other
this is very common so that is the first
thing that we need to address yeah and
see this end of itself is the subject
however I don't want to get into it
because it takes time and we need to
address it maybe in another may be
sitting shown but let us move forward
then the second issue is this brother
and sister they stopped developing their
relationship together before knowing
whether their families are going to
accept that or not and this in of itself
is a huge problem yes and my advice to
all brothers and sisters before
developing any kind of attachment to the
other side maybe you'd like to marry
data tell the sister you would like to
marry that brother but she would like he
would like but they should not take it
further because if they took it further
yes and they become people developed
love between both of them it will be
very difficult for both of them to
separate from each other yes and then
the problem will be increased on do some
really huge well law if I have seen
brothers you know brother practising
brothers there
some of him anyone want 1kg I think as
Imam you know he was crying in front of
me because his sister oh sorry the
sister he wanted to marry she left him
and she got married to another brother
has cousin said yes and he was crying a
digital can't sleep I can't even that
unsettle it is your problem because you
develop that attachment to that system
before knowing with a she can marry you
or and parents would allow you or with
accept your proposal that's why I always
think if a brother meets a sister sister
Rita brother before they take it further
and before the - yes receives them and
they talk indicating with each other are
developing love yes they should check
whether they in sermon would allow them
to get married photon yes this is the
such an important point
now the third important point aside from
the the cold issue but it is a very
fundamental issue
now many sisters many sisters have very
bad relationship with their parents
especially with their father and
therefore their father do not support
them do not have trust in them yes
so imagine as a father my daughter is
not listening to me she's being rude to
me I don't have confidence that she's
mature enough dislocating I don't have
confidence that she's mature enough the
way they she behaves
she says book here and she said outside
the home until very late she did not
build the data truck she did not behave
in a way to tell me as a father that she
is really a mature girl then all of a
sudden she wants to get ready to a
brother obviously the first thing I
would think of such is not mature yes
especially if there is a cultural gap is
male is an age gap if there are some
other major differences or I as a father
believes that there is no compatibility
I will say just she's being emotional
she's not mature okay she is living in
this immature way so how you refuse and
then the problem stop so let us not
always blame parents okay now this is an
issue that has to be addressed then if
we took into consideration all the
previous points that I have mentioned
and there is a sister who is mature and
she really wants to marry to a suitable
brother okay and her relationship with
her father is reasonable okay good the
relationship to be honest with you I
haven't seen I deal with this marriage
problem okay and done done Wally issue
much I deal with these things on a daily
basis are you lately
I have rarely seen here a genuine and
the father is refusing to allow his
daughter to marry a suitable sir
even if there is cultural difference in
fact now most of the parents admit and
acknowledge that their total are facing
challenges their being of the future and
therefore they are being so lenient with
them in okay in terms of medical but
normally when a sister when a young
sister comes to me were telling me that
all of these stories that there is a
brother normally you know young sisters
when they come they give me stories yeah
I know the story the diametre brother is
good for his deeds these are mature
brothers and Marshall oh he's of
piranhas to know all the peace emotional
things when she sustained it to me I
came hang on hang on hang on this sister
is sitting in an emotional way and if I
think if I see that her relationship
with her forever are not that is not
that potential so it's in trouble
yeah let's say for example as you said
yeah
the situation is classically fine yeah
but the parents the very cultural
parents yes and they would like for
their daughter let's say for example I'm
Pakistani she says well yes so let's say
this area sister from Pakistan your
initial from a pakistani pakistani
origin and she wants to marry let's say
for example a jamaican problem yeah
let's say for example yeah happy and
he's a good brother he's had a good
upbringing a good brother mashallah but
her parents are saying no on the basis
that he is black yeah okay he does her
dad's willy ago no agenda as simple as
that yes first of all what i am saying
is that if the system gained the trust
of the father yes if she is behaving in
a mature way yeah yes if she has a good
relationship with their father it is
very rare that her father would refute
something like this okay moreover if
there is a trust between her and her
father she was not him as well she was
not his judgment judgment yeah so if he
if he was to say her your food if you
want to take her darling you know I
don't think that there is a
compatibility I think there are many
major differences between you and him
she will accept that in in most cases
yes because he I want to say to my
sisters my own daughter
that you know what why what why I swear
by Allah that you know generally
speaking I have a theory that say a
female or the female is the most
influential individual in this world the
most industries is the most influential
individual in this world you okay it's
the most influential person in your life
you might say my here yes you just have
some influence I think bottom your
mother I think it's mama yes your mother
it's not your mother
your wife is not your wife later on it
will be your daughter you know okay you
know if my daughter comes to me yes and
she did taggi
yeah can you get something for me just
my heart will melt down immediately and
I will just you know give up you know
give up that's it was all what you daddy
getting it yeah I game over for me and
whatever you are I will try to get it
even if it is in the moon yes so I guess
what you're saying is it comes back to
your relationship with your parents
actually exactly
so if there is not a trust yes then
there will be mutual understanding
but then this distinction and under the
daughter will really have a trust and
her father's decision yeah to not say
well he's just being difficult to me no
no no no she will really consider his
judgment yes okay
however if we see that there is an
exceptional case yes you're an
exceptional case yes I want to advise my
daughter my sister's life here okay the
exception of this er I want to advise
them my dear sister be careful don't go
behind you heaven back okay you go don't
go behind them and get married secretly
this is the most dangerous thing that
you can do even if you think that you
have a valid reason you have to take it
what is the solution you have to take it
to a proper Islamic body not just anyone
not any individual not to your friend
not to an imam not all religious person
no no no no no no no don't do that don't
fall into that message I had enough
stated of sisters who were abused okay
because they misjudged the situation
what I advised there it was I want them
to go to a proper body to judge whether
they can get married without the
permission of their father and for them
to know whether that body is a proper
body to George
that body will interview the father if
the body approved their marriage without
discussion with the father without
consulting the father without knowing
his viewpoint it means that body is the
easy what is a dodgy body it does a
generator they don't know what they are
doing is now another point that I'd like
to mention is that those sisters go
maybe secretly without the permission of
their father or without the support of a
brother body normally those girls those
daughters are abused by their husband
wallahi
we have so many cases of sisters who
were humiliated you know humiliated by
their husband why sit on a lot happened
in my family that's in my family one one
of the girls she run away with this guy
literally [ __ ] a month or two month
later he's beating the crap out exactly
he's beating her yet why you know why we
are men okay we know the man when he
deals with a man he knows that or he
understands me the I understand him we
speak on the same level I can't take
advantage of him he comes take advantage
of me yeah so I will respect him I will
have Y and it's some kind of fool
yes but if that is enough that when
there's no consequences when he knows
there's no consequence yet if that is
enough that what will happen he will
take advantage of hurt you and he will
humiliate that's why it needs to be done
yes proper so she obviously we know
generally in Islam the valley of the
woman yes my father genuine yeah
let's say now for example there's a lot
of situations with the dad can't be the
one he maybe is not Muslim
maybe he passed away maybe there's a
situation where he can't be the Lally
who should be next in line yeah it is
that were okay see first of all first of
all yes it is true that the Prophet
Allah Allah where you observe yourself
is there is Monica without the
permission of Flowery yes yes also hand
the Prophet Allah said instead a human
right instant know what is really even
even a year any lady that got married
without the permission of head well it
means the original one it is not just
anyone
and this is a common mistake because
some sisters yes they have they have
problems with their parents with the
father and then she picked anyone for
all the three and if under he becomes
her one not on all this is true well III
know I dealt with a case runrunrun
brothers in his own took look at this
joke there are so many jokes too
one can attract interest yes he came to
me after a lecture about marriage and he
said to me yes I wanted to get married
to a sister I came to know her
matrimonial so one of those who
authorizes the app and then riccati to
communicate with her he lose that
country in order to be her mother and
father review okay no it was back
what did he do he flew again deduction
he meant with answer in the airport and
as it approached a friend of hers a
friend of hers uh Nelson
okay so after thoroughly and the brother
he brought through his head as utilities
and they done Zenica yeah in the airport
okay and then she go with him to his
country and then that brother yeah he
trying now I just with his team he is
crying because her father is not
accepting the automatic I said to mahi
well ma he will lie if that happened to
your daughter
you will never accept that man who got
married to you daughter because you feel
that this is a disease that he just
kidnapped your daughter mighty point is
the sister yes
cannot decide that her father we don't
know and he needs to be a body we've
established that but now so he is in a
severe body neutral body yes yes to
judge properly whether the father cannot
be the worry okay and when that body
will decide who will be
what okay okay so brothers and sisters
exactly so for watching I hope this has
been very very beneficial and insightful
for anyone going through similar
problems or knows anyone going through
things like this guys if you would like
a question of yours answered inshallah
marketing Simone Haddad email us at the
email that is below in Sharla and
inshallah we will get back to you just
like a reserved for watching take care
of yourself Melanie
[Music]
[Music]